il a été obligé de quitter son domicile
en pleine nuit après avoir reçu de
nombreux appels anonymes de menaces ces
appels feraient suite à aux questions du
père de famille sur un projet de
construction d'une mosquée petit récap
et il sera avec nous juste après tu peux
rester hein tu avec grand plaisir tu vas
te mettre tu vas te mettre à côté de du
coup je suis payé à partir de janvier
non allez tu peux partir
regarde depuis quelques jours en région
parisienne un homme a fer me vivre un
véritable calvaire un homme menacé de
mort à Manille et amau dans les Yvelines
le trentenaire déclare avoir reçu de
nombreux messages et des appels anonymes
menaçants il vit dans l'angoisse et le
maire de la ville ne lui apporte aucun
soutien la raison de cette situation il
aurait posé des questions concernant un
projet de mosquée et serait accusé
d'islamophobie face aux menaces l'homme
et sa famille ont donc dû quitter en
urgence leur logement alors que se
passe-t-il pierrelouis témoigne ce soir
dans
TPMP merci d'être avec nous pierrelouis
vous avez dû quitter votre quitter votre
logement avec votre famille après avoir
posé une question sur un projet de
mosquée on va revenir sur cette à faire
euh qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
racontez-nous déjà l'histoire à la base
en fait tout a commencé il y a quelques
semaines quelques mois on a créé avec
des habitants de ma commune donc
manilamo c'est une petite commune de
10000 habitants dans les Yvelines à la
campagne d'cord on a créé un ce qu'on
appelait un comité de citoyens qui avait
un objectif très simple qui est
de de préserver et améliorer le le cadre
et la qualité de vie dans notre commune
donc à partir de là en fait on était
vraiment en vigilance sur différents
sujets sur voilà sur ce qui se passe
dans notre
ville et en fait il y a quelques temps
on a été on a été alerté par plusieurs
habitants qui sur un un projet de
mosquée qui ne dit pas son nom mené par
la mairie euh donc face à cette opacité
voilà si c'est flou c'est qu'il y a un
loup c'est vraiment ça notre
raisonnement face à cette opacité on a
uniquement poser des questions pour
savoir ce que serait concrètement le
projet euh d'où viennent les
financements où sera le
projet quelle obédience il sera en place
et cetera on posait ces questions
vraiment dans un objectif de d'intérêt
général pour l'ensemble des habitants et
pour aussi la la communauté musulmane
donc je tiens ici à à redire qu'on a
aucune hostilité et la démarche n'était
vraiment pas une démarche d'hostilité
vis-à-vis de la communauté musulmane de
manilamoo mais uniquement une une
démarche d'information pour l'ensemble
de la commune qui bénéficiera à tous
alors vous avez reçu des menaces de mort
ensuite oui donc donc ensuite euh il y a
eu un soir où mon numéro a fuité euh et
donc j'étais avec ma femme chez moi et à
partir de 23h30 jusque jusqu'à minut 300
on a reçu une dizaine d'appels en numéro
masqué et en fait tous ces appels se
terminé par par des menaces de mort on
va vous massacrer un par un on a votre
adresse on va venir chez vous donc suite
à ça on a quitté vers 2h du matin notre
logement pour aller se réfugier ailleurs
euh donc avec avec ma femme et nos deux
enfants euh voilà donc on c'était pas
très vous avez V domicile en pleine nuit
c'est ça vous sentez que vous sentiez
que la menace était était vraiment bah
en fait c'est la la menace est très
difficile à à Jer euh ce qui s'est passé
aussi c'est que dans les appels qu'on a
eu on a eu un qui venait d'une jeune
fille qui nous a expliqué que donc mes
informations mon nom mon numéro et avec
le qualificatif de islamophobe et
raciste circuler sur snapchat euh donc
voilà en fait c'est ça qui est très
compliqué à cerner c'est quel est le
niveau réel de menace euh c'est une
information qui peut qui peut circuler
sur les réseaux sociaux elle circule euh
donc voilà le le c'est ça qui est
compliqué pour nous c'est de de savoir
réellement ce qu'il faut faire est-ce
qu'on peut continuer à vivre normalement
c'est ce qu'on souhaite nous on est
vraiment dans une logique d'apaisement
euh de de de pouvoir mener une vie
normale c'est bien que vous expliquz ce
soir oui gine bon toutes les menaces
sont insupportables donc totale
solidarité vous avez eu raison de porter
plainte vous l'avez fait maintenant ma
question all est simple si c'était une
église vous auriez fait la même chose
bien sûr en fait c'est très simple nous
on est sur vraiment sur des sujets
locaux euh s'il y avait un projet
d'église avec de l'opacité et un risque
un risque d'extrémisme on serait
mobilisé de la même façon d'accord
oui donc c'est important de le dire ce
soir aussi ou merci non c'est euh vous
avez reçu une nouvell menace de mort
depuis ou pas non non ça y est ça s'est
ça s'est calmé les choses sont calmées
après ça les les les débats continuent à
être très virulents notamment sur des
groupes facebook ou autres euh le maire
de votre ville vous a contacté vous avez
é changé avec lui non non pas du tout
non non non non euh ça c'est un sujet
euh un sujet particulier où voilà je
sais pas s'il un manque de communication
avec la mairie ou pas mais le le maire
qui est au courant de tout ça ne nous a
pas contacté et euh a au contraire
diffusé et en train de diffuser un tract
euh dans l'ensemble de la ville dans
lequel euh il dit sans nous viser
explicitement il dénonce les les
racistes les xénophobes qui appellent à
la haine et il dit que c'est AB donc
voilà moi je je dénonce aussi le le je
trouve ça assez responsable que le
premier magistrat de la ville qui qui
est aussi le qui est aussi un officier
de police judiciaire par mandat voilà
enfin je F ce genre de message qui en
fait ça ça jette de l'h sur le feu donc
j'espère que c'est uniquement un manque
de communication et je le souhaite euh
je suis pas certain les gendarmes
surveillent votre domicile ou pas du
tout
oui il y a des patrouilles des
patrouilles renforcées sur vous êtes
revenu chez vous alors vous êtes
retourné euh non pas tout à fait on est
revenu chez nous mais là on est suite à
la sortie justement de l'article du JDD
on a préféré prendre de la distance ou
c'est ça oui pourquoi aujourd'hui vous
sentez vraiment que ça c'est c'est chaud
encore une fois c'est vraiment difficile
à cerner et voilà on préférait être
prudent je super de famille j'ai deux
enfants j'ai une épouse Manamo est une
petite commune les choses les choses
circulent vite euh voilà on on préfère
être prudent vous avez porté plin ou pas
oui bien sûr ouis et euh pour menace de
mort et appel malveillant ouais c'est
c'est c'est c'est incroyable alors
aujourd'hui il en est où le le projet va
va avancer de toute façon alors le le
nous notre demande elle a pas changé
hein on demande toujours des
informations
euh donc je je sais pas exactement où on
est le projet c'est il y a toujours
cette opacité euh qu'est-ce qui vous
fait peur en fait dans ce projet alors
il y a rien
de qu'est-ce qui me fait peur a priori
rien c'est ça que je tiens à dire a
priori rien uniquement on demande
uniquement des
informations en fait pour vous dire on
est un département où si y a des un
risque de salafisme qui existe voilà
vous pourrez lire l'article du JDD qui
en parle donc nous en fait cette
démarche on considère vraiment c'est de
l'intérêt général au niveau local pour
toute la population et en particulier
aussi pour la communauté musulmane c'est
dans dans l'intérêt de tous pour nos
enfants pour pour l'ensemble de la
population d'accord vous avez dit j'ai
souhaité devenir membre du comité
citoyen de votre ville pour m'investir
dans une démarche citoyenne qui s'oppose
à certaines pratiques du maire aussi le
maire qui est encarté chez génération s
le parti fondé par Benoît amont c'est ça
ou et et donc oui pour dans la ville ça
se passe mal et
pour non non bah après ça c'est c'est
aussi la rédaction de l'article qui
accentue ces points là moi je voilà j'ai
des divergences avec le avec le maire
j'ai des convictions qui sont propre à
titre personnel euh après c'est une
ville c'est une ville agréable mais
voilà nous on est vraiment dans un but
d'intérêt local il y a plusieurs sujets
ou ça peut être de l'aménagement
l'urbanisme où on est on est en
vigilance
euh voilà c'est en fait c'est la base de
la démocratie locale les les communautés
de citoyens c'est des citoyens qui qui
se rassemblent entre eux et qui euh et
et et qui qui qui sont en vigilance sur
ce qui se passe dans la commune et qui
sont dans une optique de dialogue euh
voilà pour moi c'est vraiment la base de
la démocratie merci pierrelouis d'avoir
été avec nous je vous prie merci
beaucoup on va suivre ça également dans
un instant on va revenir sur la soirée
Miss France bien sûr avec un très très
gros débrief et on aura Miss Guadeloupe
avec nous qui était la miss Guyane excm
qui était la la favorite du public et
puis on verra sur cette vidéo qui a
énormément fait parler cette vidéo viral
de Franck tapirot qui vient souvent nous
voir ici et il viendra nous voir pour
nous donner les les explications bien
sûr sur voilà cette vidéo qui a
énormément tourné on sera dans un
instant en direct dans TPMP à tout de
suite